so there I was browsing Twitter minding
my own business went back the brand new
cover art for the latest dragon ball
game Kakarot surfaced online needless to
say I had some thoughts about it and so
being the tactful and respectful person
that I am
I sent my thoughts out into the Twitter
sphere okay fine maybe I did go a little
overboard with the criticism but I did
think it was boring and oh my did other
people agree in both liking retweeting
and in the comments down below this
tweet however I think it goes without
saying that this perspective has its
detractors too many considered this
cover to be great and others went as far
as to call me disrespectful and cold my
ability to make a better one into
question so today I'm gonna put my money
where my mouth is today I'm gonna make
the Dragon Ball Z Kakarot cover I always
wanted I hope I don't screw this up
alrighty so in order to begin this
ridiculous task I opened up my trusty
drawing application paint tool Sai after
setting the resolution and dimensions to
the Mike computer hates me now setting I
began conceptualizing so in a nutshell
what I wanted to do was to create a
snapshot of Goku so to speak something
that either captures some of his story
or his personality I mean the game is
called Kakarot after all and I think
that opens up lots of possibilities for
an interesting cover and honestly that
really was my problem with the official
cover it's completely inoffensive and
honestly just really really easy tons of
games are doing box art like this now
and I honestly expected more from the
cover when the title of the game is
Kakarot there's just so much that can be
done with that concept alone so before I
started drawing anything I made mental
notes of what I thought about when I
said the name khakkhara
I thought of Goku Super Saiyans his
staff Nimbus Dragon Balls the Moon
Frieza etc now I knew I couldn't use all
of these but I did want to include most
of them and that's when I started
mapping out a really rough composition
which honestly was weird because I was
also drawing something with the
knowledge that a decent chunk of it will
be covered by logos titles and headers
for the games casing
however after drawing landscape
thumbnails on YouTube for god knows
how long drawing in portrait felt fresh
and offered a lot in the way of
composition and for those that don't
know composition is how you orientate or
format your drawing or artwork think of
it as the blueprint for a house a
composition layout is sort of the
blueprint for the final art piece and so
I started doodling
I began by outlining the shapes I wanted
for this cover where certain characters
would be and what I would be putting
where because it's a game cover we are
creating here and not just a nice piece
of artwork I needed to be conscious of
where the title for the game would be
such that it wouldn't obstruct anything
important and that the eye would be
drawn to it I gotta sell those copies
after all thankfully a lifetime of
making youtube thumbnails prepared me
for such a problem I put a nice big
semicircle at the top who knows I might
put a moon there or something I mean it
does hold significance with Goku's life
after all it is part of his Saiyan
ancestry however since the game is
called Kakarot I just didn't think one
Goku on the cover would be enough
there's always being two sides to the
character at least a kind innocent side
and another that gets very serious with
all is on the line with this in mind I
opted to scribble down onto the canvas
a crude kid Goku and his Super Saiyan
transformation as fitting
representations of this characters
duality I swear I'll draw better than
this later once this outstanding display
of drawing humility is over with and I
have any idea of where the hell I'm
going with this I move on to the sketch
phase using this as my basis for
composition from here on in as you've
probably already noticed in addition to
drawing an outstanding kid Goku earlier
I also drew his space pod the idea I had
was to have on one cover a beginning and
an end for the character I wanted to
draw his first moments outside the
capsule after landing on earth confused
and apprehensive with his older more
serious Super Saiyan form roaring behind
him confidently to draw
Kakarot I used Dragon Ball super bro Li
when referencing the armor the pose
however came from the top of my head
once I was satisfied with the sketch I
began sketching the pot he arrived again
using reference of the craft from Dragon
Ball super broadly in order to
understand how the inside worked and I
grabbed a picture from Google Images all
at all this little guy was fun and a
nice change of pace enjoyed the typical
Dragon Ball adult characters I always do
with that said now it's time to draw the
typical adult Dragon Ball characters I
always do as the second pair of this
cover art I wanted the innocence of the
younger Goku to be in direct contrast
with the older more serious side of
himself while following the initial
composition blueprint I began drawing a
front view of a Super Saiyan Goku old
pretty standard stuff tried to get the
face right spent some time in the jaw
and face shape drawing his ears in and
his neck however there was one minor
problem the drawing was trashed and
needed to be destroyed
needless to say starting over wasn't
exactly my favorite thing to do after
dedicating a decent chunk of time to
this drawing but this is Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot dad it deserves my best so I
started again this time trying a
slightly more difficult angle but it is
one of my favorites from a frontal view
and I'm happy to announce that I was
much much happier with how the head
turned out for this one that being said
I still had to draw all of the body and
I'm sure that won't take forever I have
to spend in what felt like four hours
referencing tons of real-life muscle
groups I decided to call it a day with
the body considering most of it will be
obscured by a small child with a
spaceship anyway which makes my inner
artist cry but these are the sacrifices
we make in the name of progress right as
part of the next step I shed a tear as I
hide the screaming Saiyans perfect ABS
behind the young armored Goku when
something terrible comes to my attention
the composition doesn't work at all
predominantly because the kid Goku and
the pudgy caiman are standing in
three-quarter pose while the screaming
Super Saiyan is fronting something needs
to change here and while I love this
cute little Goku sketch there's
absolutely no way I'm discarding the
screaming Super Saiyan that easily took
me two hours to fully render which means
you guessed it I have to discard this
little Goku ski
and start from scratch yes I'm not
kidding but I mean who needs sleep my
dad always said real gold doesn't fear
trial-by-fire
so here I go marching into the flames
burning the candle at both ends
since I had already drawn Goku with his
armor on I decided to draw Goku from the
very first chapter of Dragonball without
it instead and that's what I had an idea
for a really fun visual so the first
thing I'm gonna do is make sure that
this image of kid Goku is drawn front
done no more composition mistakes this
time but one thing I did want to do was
to recreate the praying pose Goku
assumed at the beginning of the story
with the four star ball and with the
color scheme I have in mind I think it's
gonna look awesome I hope in truth
discarding the last kid Goku sketch was
upsetting but this new one I'm actually
much happier with both from a
compositional perspective and an
artistic one he just looked so damn cute
and I love this idea of him praying to
the Dragon Ball it really helps tie the
whole piece together and works well
within the composition it being
perfectly in line with the two other
heads straight down the middle of the
canvas drawing his little hands in
prayer was a little tricky at first but
I settled on a pose I was happy with
eventually I checked the final
composition with the Super Saiyan
illustration and I got it works so now
that we're happy with the sketching
composition we move on to the most
satisfying part the line art this was
probably the most time-consuming part in
isolation despite it not requiring much
thought at all I did fix and change a
few things as I went through with the
anatomy additionally in areas that
lacked detail like the mouth I took the
time to add the appropriate detail to
the roof the tongue and the teeth I
played around with the idea of adding
veins to his face also you know
reminiscent of the original animes
transformation but in the end I thought
it was going a little overboard and so I
opted to move forward without them
however the biggest task had to be the
hair so it's just as well hair is my
favorite thing to draw on a character
Dragon Ball has a lot of different ways
to draw hair the Lego looks solid color
wavy but I instead of going the routes a
lot of modern Dragonball likes to take I
try to make each bunching of hair assume
its own unique shape consistency along
with random strands poking out here and
there like regular hair tends to do I
love the results this approach heals and
it's the way I almost always draw my
hair I'm not trying to recreate our
mimic a style that said it's not exactly
a time sensitive practice
and the light alone took well over an
hour to finish with the hair I rechecked
the composition to make sure everything
is lining up correctly moment of truth
time I really don't want to redraw
anything and thank God it works but one
tiny little thing is still bothering me
about this now it's not a big deal and
thankfully it's an easy fix you see that
little tail there
well that tail unbalances the entire
piece you see there's nothing on the
other side of the image to
counterbalance that tail so let's add
something I still have to draw the
shredded pants and shirt bits from the
Super Saiyan Goku illustration so I
figured the belt would be a fitting way
to fill up that negative space and
surprise surprise it doli was the
tattered clothes look about right but
really this whole thing really comes
together when we add color in the
comments under my original tweet folks
seem to like the red backdrop of the
original piece so let's keep that now
what inspired the color pad I want to
use for this piece came from an idea I
had for the Dragon Ball itself instead
of going with traditional colors I
wanted it to glow but instead of showing
you the entire process of me gloriously
coloring it seriously it took about four
hours I want you to get the full effect
on first viewing so three two one as you
can see the glow I use for the Dragon
Ball I mirrored with the glow of the
Super Saiyan hair I use nice and warm
colors for the skin tones and the
clothes on both characters I also added
these veins of light to the Dragon Ball
that I thought added this mystical
quality to it there are dozens of layers
at work for the color alone and the
entire piece has close to a hundred
layers total my computer might have
crashed a number of times getting to
this point but we are not done while
looking at this you might have noticed
that there is a little pink glow on alt
Goku shoulders and arms that's because
we have one more thing to add that ties
this entire piece together
unfortunately because I'm an idiot I
forgot to record this part but I do have
the line art and the color layers for
you guys to check out in isolation
essentially I wanted a villain to look
ominously from behind and who better of
your lid for Goku than Frieza he is a
long history with the character and is
the reason for his being sent to earth
in the first place I ended up drawing
his face in full but in reality I only
needed his eyes and a pink load to be
emitted from them to offset the yellows
and oranges from the main piece I know I
said I wanted to include the moon
the beginning but I think this works
better here and there you have it now is
the time for the moment of truth where
we add the logos age warnings branding
and game case header to reveal the final
piece I give you my interpretation of
the Dragon Ball Z Kakarot video game box
art no I'm going to sleep huh if you
like this artwork don't forget to leave
a like and subscribe for more thank you
so much for watching
[Music]